bienvenidos a enlace conosur en esta
emisión desde buenos aires argentina
nuestro tema de hoy porque argentina que
alguna vez estuvo entre las naciones más
ricas de latinoamerica hace unos 25 años
que no logra que la pobreza baje más
allá del 20 por ciento estamos un repaso
a las cifras para explorar por qué pese
a que todos los gobiernos lo enfrentaron
el problema no sólo persiste sino que
viene creciendo en años recientes hoy
también la universidad de buenos aires
que ha educado a generaciones y
generaciones de estudiantes cumple dos
siglos de vida la uba como se conoce en
argentina es todo un emblema de nuestro
país
en un país con mayoría de población
creciente que pasó durante la pandemia
con el santuario de una de las llamadas
santas populares con más seguidores del
país la difunta correa lo visitamos en
la provincia de san juan
a mis espaldas está la plaza de mayo
frente a la casa de gobierno de
argentina la casa rosada- construida a
fines del siglo 19 cuando el país se
encontraba en un proceso de crecimiento
que lo llevó a estar entre los más ricos
del mundo la arquitectura de este
edificio y de cientos de otros de esa
época en la ciudad son prueba viviente
de ello este lugar ha sido y es
escenario de múltiples eventos de la
historia del país y también de
persistentes protestas
dependiendo de los cálculos entre un 42
por ciento y la mitad de los argentinos
se encuentran hoy debajo de la línea de
la pobreza y de acuerdo con cifras
oficiales más del 10 por ciento están
debajo de la línea de la indigencia lo
que implica que no pueden acceder ni
siquiera a la canasta básica alimentaria
cerca de 40 años con la llegada de la
democracia a la pobreza estaba en torno
al 22 por ciento y si bien en los años
siguientes cayó la hiperinflación de
1989 la volvió a hacer subir y se
disparó aún más con la crisis de
2001-2002
2003 volvió a darse un descenso
sostenido hasta 2013 aunque la calidad
de las cifras oficiales entre 2007 y
2015 es seriamente cuestionada
históricamente argentina era considerada
en el contexto latinoamericano como una
nación con una importante clase media
aún hoy se encuentra en el lugar número
46 de 160 en el índice de desarrollo
humano de las naciones unidas- pero la
realidad es que de todos modos el país
no logra controlar la pobreza por eso
combatirla ha sido una promesa un
desafío de todos los gobiernos desde el
regreso de la democracia por lo menos de
todos los presidentes que pasaron por
este edificio estos son algunos de los
más recientes
porque siempre
va a faltar la victoria definitiva
mientras haya un pobre en la patria esto
lo tenemos muy claro
nuestra prioridad será lograr un país
donde cada día haya más igualdad de
oportunidades en el que no haya
argentinos que pasen hambre
decimos ser el país que produce
alimentos para 400 millones de personas
y no podemos alimentar a 15 millones de
personas nuestras que están en situación
de pobreza
cada uno de sus gobiernos trajo su
propia receta para resolver el problema
pero ninguno logró hacerlo en forma
sostenible le preguntamos por qué a
sebastián wise grace quien trabaja sobre
el tema de la pobreza en unicef
argentina
básicamente en los últimos 70 años el
país atravesó 15 crisis económicas
y cada una de ellas dejó un piso de
pobreza superior
y quizás esta es la razón por la cual en
las últimas décadas el país nunca fue
capaz de perforar
en el caso de la hiniesta adolescencia o
un piso de pobreza del 30% es un poco
más bajo en la población en general
dijimos al inicio del programa que
también íbamos a hablar de los 200 años
de la más grande universidad de
argentina la universidad de buenos aires
esa casa de estudio se inauguró el 12 de
agosto de 1821 a 100 metros de aquí en
la iglesia de san ignacio desde esos
inicios pasó por varias etapas y una
constante expansión es hoy la
universidad pública más grande del país
en la actualidad y mayoritariamente en
forma remota por la pandemia en sus
trece facultades cursan carreras de
grado y posgrado más de 320 mil alumnos
guiados por más de 30.000 docentes antes
de despedirnos en américa latina está
muy difundido el culto a los llamados
santos populares en argentina un país de
mayoría católica existen varias de estas
figuras las zonas donde están instalados
sus santuarios o lugares de
peregrinación viven del turismo
religioso son economías que también se
vieron afectadas por la pandemia de kobe
19 como la de la localidad de vallecitos
en san juan en el óxido entre el país
viajamos hasta allí
para ellos que creen es una cuestión de
fe llegan hasta aquí hasta esta loma
para visitar pero también para pedir y
para agradecer son promesantes hacen una
promesa que cumplen si sienten que se
les otorgó lo que piden muchos están
regresando por primera vez desde el
inicio de la pandemia la venimos a dar
gracias por haber pasado esta pandemia
por la salud de ellos especialmente las
familias del lugar viven del comercio
con los turistas todavía no terminan de
recuperarse de los meses de cuarentena
cuando se ha reabierto era muy poca la
gente que venía que no sabía que el
santuario estaba abierto y bueno y con
muchos protocolos
solamente el 40 por ciento de capacidad
pero poco a poco regresan a medida que
la pandemia retrocede al menos por ahora
en argentina vuelven para subir del modo
en que hayan prometido estos 180
escalones
gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de enlace conosur desde buenos aires
argentina pueden enviarnos a nuestras
redes sociales comentarios y sugerencias
de temas que les gustaría que exploremos
en el programa los invito ahora a seguir
con la programación de france 24 en
español hasta la próxima